in this video you're going to learn how
to work with parabolas by putting them
into these standard forms so that you
can identify the vertex the focus the
directrix and get a nice sketch of your
graph so these are the two equations
that we're going to be working with and
we're going to be talking about how to
put it into that form so that we can get
a nice sketch now keep in mind when you
talk about a parabola what a parabola is
it's the set of all points that are
equidistant from a given point called
the focus and a given line called the
directrix so for example if I had a
point right here the distance from that
point to the focus would be the same
distance as that perpendicular distance
to the directrix and as you get further
and further out on the parabola the
distance the focus gets longer but so
does the distance to the directrix but
those two distances will always be the
same so that distance right here from
the focus to the vertex we call that
distance p and the distance from the
vertex to the directrix that's also
equal to p and you'll see that come me
into play in both of these equations so
let's go through two examples I'll show
you how this works the first thing we
want to do is identify what type of form
this is in is it a y squared type or an
x squared type well it looks like this
is going to be like a y squared type so
this is the form we're going to be
trying to get it into so let's get
everything that has a y on the left side
of the equation
and everything that doesn't have a y
let's move it to the right so we're
going to add 4X to the right
subtract 29
and then now what we're going to do is
we're going to complete the square so
we're going to take half of B and square
it so we take half of this coefficient
half of 10 is 5 and if we square that 5
squared is 5 times 5 that's 25 if we add
25 to the left side of the equation we
want to add it to the right to keep it
balanced right now we're going to do is
we're just going to factor this left
side and the way this factors it's going
to be a perfect square a binomial
squared and it's going to be y plus 5
the quantity squared it'll always be
half of this B value if this was minus
10y you'd see this is y minus 5. so
that's kind of a quick shortcut
and you can always check your work if
you write y plus 5 times y plus 5 and
foil it out you'll get back that
original
now over here if we simplify we get 4X
negative 29 plus 5 is negative 4. and
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to factor out this coefficient here in
front of the X so in this case I'm going
to factor out a 4. and that's going to
leave us with x minus 1 on the right
and on the left we have y plus 5 the
quantity squared okay so now we have it
in this form and we can identify the
vertex now what you want to be careful
of is you want to make sure you take the
x coordinate of the vertex is grouped
with the X so that's going to be
positive 1.
and the y coordinate of the vertex is
grouped with the Y that's going to be
negative 5. also notice that the signs
are flipped so if this is negative 1
this is positive one if this is positive
5 this is negative 5. just remember X is
with the X and the Y is with the Y now
let's go ahead and graph this so 1
negative 5 puts us right here that's our
vertex and we have to kind of now
identify as the graph going to open up
or down or right or left right and when
it's a y squared type and this p-value
is positive it opens to the right if the
p-value is negative it opens to the left
so the way we find p is we take this
coefficient here 4 and we set it equal
to 4p so let's do that 4p equals 4
divide both sides by 4 P equals one
notice it's positive so our Parabola is
going to be opening to the right so if I
go one space to the right that's our
focus and so that's going to be at 2
negative 5.
and if we go one to the left that's
going to be our directrix
and that is the line X is equal to zero
x lines are vertical lines so we can see
that this distance from the vertex to
the directrix and the vertex of the
focus is the same that's our P distance
that's one and one in this case now the
other thing is that the parabola keeps
getting wider as you you know go further
and further out right but at the level
of the focus it's always going to be 4
times p y that's called a focal chord
and in this case 4p is equal to four so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to cut
that four and a half so I'm going to go
up to
I'm going to go down to
and that's just a way of getting a
couple easy points to locate on your
Parabola of course you can see it's
getting wider but this distance right
here is 4p which is 4. so let's go ahead
and take a look at another example okay
let's try example number two if you're
getting the hang of this maybe you might
want to try this one on your own and
then you can see as we go through it if
you've got it right so for number two it
looks like see this is x squared so it's
going to be this type right here so
we're going to do is we're going to get
everything that has an x on the left
side of our equation
and everything else we're going to move
to the right side so I'm going to
subtract 8y
and I'm going to subtract 40 so that
becomes a negative 40. okay so now what
we're going to do is we're going to
complete the square so we take half of
this coefficient half the B value and we
Square it half of negative 8 is negative
4 negative 4 squared is negative 4 times
negative 4 which is a positive 16. if we
add 16 to the left we have to add 16 to
the right to keep our equation balanced
right
now what we're going to do is we're
going to factor this left side and
that's going to factor to x minus 4 the
quantity squared remember it's always
half of this B value if this is plus 8X
it'd be plus 4. and then on the right
side let's simplify a little bit we have
negative 8y
and this is going to be minus 24. now
what we want to do is we want to factor
out this coefficient in front of the Y
so if we factor out a negative 8 that's
going to leave us with Y plus 3
and over here we have x minus 4 the
quantity squared now it's in this form
and we can identify our vertex which is
the H comma K again remember the one
that's grouped with the X that's going
to be your x coordinate of your vertex
and the one group with your Y is going
to be your y-coordinate of your vertex
but remember the signs are the opposite
see x minus 4 it's positive 4 y plus 3
it's negative 3. so let's go ahead and
graph that one two three four one two
negative 3 right about here
and now let's figure out is it going to
open up down left or right well first we
want to do is we want to find our
p-value so we can see 4p is equal to
negative 8. so if we set those equal to
each other and divide by 4 p is equal to
negative two but remember when it's an x
squared type it's either going to go up
if p is positive or it's going to open
down like this if p is negative so in
this case p is negative so we know our
Parabola is going to be opening down and
if I go down 2 from this point which is
going to be right about here
okay that's going to be our Focus that's
our vertex and if we go up to that's
going to put us right here
that's our DirectX remember the distance
from the vertex to the directrix is the
same as the distance from the vertex to
the focus that's our P distance which in
this case was 2.
and let's see write our equation here so
our focus and our directory so our
directrix is this horizontal line that's
the line Y equals negative one remember
horizontal lines are y equals lines and
then the focus is going to be here at
let's see 4 negative 3 went down so it's
4 negative 5.
and then remember at the level the focus
we said it's 4p wide so in this case 4p
is equal to 8 so it's going to be 8 wide
at the level of the focus so I'm going
to cut the eight and a half I'm going to
go 4 to the right which is let's see one
two three four right about here I'm
going to go 4 to the left which is going
to be right about here and that kind of
gives us an idea about how wide our
Parabola is
at the level of the focus so again
remember this distance right here is 4p
and we said that was 8 and I just cut it
in half four to the right and four to
the left gives us a good sketch so if
you like the way that I'm explaining
these conic sections parabolas are part
of conic sections I'm going to put a
video right there that goes more into
depth into not just parabolas but
ellipses hyperbolas circles so you're
definitely going to want to learn more
about these connects follow me over to
that video there and we'll get some more
practice I'll see you in that video